If you're used to working with mobile
devices then your primary input
device is a touch screen that's
always going to be connected
unless your device is
having a very bad day.
By contrast, TV remote controls and
game controllers are usually
connected via Bluetooth.
Because they're battery powered
controllers often sleep to save power,
shutting down their radios after
a couple minutes of unuse.
In this lesson,
we'll learn how to handle connect and
disconnect events from input devices.
The InputManager fires events when
devices are connected or disconnected,
and it provides a method for
us to register an InputDeviceListener,
which we can use to
subscribe to these events.
Here they are, you can probably
guess what two of these mean.
OnInputDeviceAdded and
onInputDeviceRemoved are triggered when
devices are connected or disconnected.
OnInputDeviceChanged is
a little bit different.
Typically, input devices don't
change but they certainly can.
For example,
you can imagine a game controller
might have two different modes.
A good strategy for dealing with a
change event is to simply disconnect and
then reconnect the device.
Let's see how our asteroids
game handles this, and
we'll start back in the GameView.
The fist thing to notice is that our
view implements the InputDeviceListener
interface, and we'll see where
this is defined in a sec.
Once we've implemented that interface,
all we need to do is override
those three methods we discussed.
Here's onInputDeviceAdded.
What's cool here is that when
a controller is connected our game
gets the device ID and
then creates a ship for it.
We maintain a mapping from
ship to input device and
in this way we can support
multiple players easily.
When a controller is disconnected
we simply remove the ship
corresponding to that device ID.
Pretty easy, right?
Here we are in the constructor
of our game view.
The last step is to get a reference
to the InputManager and
then register our view as Listener for
it.
Rather than directly
accessing the system classes,
we use the InputManagerCompat
provided by the controller sample.
This is code that you're free to reuse.
It abstracts the way differences and
how input devices are handled across
different versions of Android.
Instead of designing your game to work
within InputManager from a specific
Android version, you can design your
game logic against InputManagerCompat.
This class contains a factory
method which behind the scenes
will instantiate an appropriate
concrete implementation
depending on which version of Android
your game happens to be running on.
And you can see that Factory
method inside InputManagerCompat
right down here at the bottom.
And by the way, the Factory designed
pattern is one of my favorites, and
I highly recommend learning it
if you haven't seen it before.